y qué mensaje quiere enviar entonces el
gobierno colombiano encabezado por el
presidente de petro al suspender estos
bombardeos y como seguirá entonces
combatiendo esta lucha armada que
todavía se mantiene contra algunos
grupos guerrilleros y contra otros
grupos al margen de la ley porque los
bombardeos son claves en su desarrollo
de sus tácticas militares
para toda la audiencia yo creo que es
importante resaltar que los bombardeos
no van a dejar de existir pasa es que lo
que planteó el gobierno de pedro en este
momento fue que iba a sorprender
aquellos bombardeos donde hubiera la
posibilidad de que menores de edad
estudiando en los
un sitio donde estaban donde estuvieran
los miembros de estos grupos
comerciantes y otras
organizaciones
esta es una práctica que en el pasado
reciente ha tenido una crítica enorme
porque los menores de edad terminan
siendo los tres afectados y creo que
hace parte con la lógica de campaña de
gustavo petro a lo largo de los últimos
meses sin embargo también es importante
tener en cuenta que este anuncio puede
ser muy perjudicial porque este anuncio
teléfono se hizo lo que hacemos
un incentivo perverso hacia estos grupos
en donde claro el reclutamiento de
menores siempre va a ser criticado y
siempre se considera un delito pero
cuando el gobierno anuncia esto los
grupos van a saber que si tienen menores
nunca van a ser atacados y esto va a
convertirse en ese sentido perverso
donde el reclutamiento va a aumentar en
lugar de tener ese impacto positivo en
torno a la protección de la vida de los
menores es una es un juego muy
significado el gobierno está planteando
que hay que tener en cuenta en ese
sentido las normas y as en ese orden de
ideas entonces qué opciones plantea el
gobierno colombiano para contrarrestar
esta posibilidad de aumentar el
reclutamiento de menores o de concentrar
en ciertos lugares del país a mayor
cantidad de menores reclutados
precisamente para evitar bombardeos y
presencia de militares a través de estos
actos militares
es algo que el gobierno como reacción a
su estrategia plantea para evitar y
proteger el reclutamiento son dos
diferentes
estrategias para enfrentar estos grupos
y otra cosa es lo que se realiza en
torno a la prevención y protección en
materia de reclutamiento que es algo que
hay que fortalecer sí o sí más allá y si
se realizan bombardeos o no y en el tema
los bombardeos algo que es relevante que
es muy importante es que ya existen
protocolos en ese sentido ha habido
críticas en torno a los protocolos pero
lo que hay
cuáles son esos protocolos la labor de
inteligencia militar y policial para
poder realizar esas intervenciones
militares y comunicarse enormemente en
fortalecer y proteger las leyes de
prevención profesión el reclutamiento
las normas ya rápidamente está entonces
respondiendo el gobierno colombiano a
esta desescalar de cierta forma el tipo
de conflicto que está viviendo ahora
todo esto de cara a propiciar más
garantías para una mesa de diálogo con
una guerrilla como por ejemplo la lln
y bajo qué condiciones de plan negociar
porque eso es algo que todavía no
sabemos pero es sin duda el objetivo
principal del gobierno ha gustado petro
lograr negociar con estos trucos ojalá
de manera diferenciada